oh hello hi I love Yorkies she loves
Yorkies hi I'm Shadow I'm very friendly
could have fooled me shadow and I love
meeting new people I'm also very
energetic and playful and I love
spending time exploring Outdoors
sometimes I'm a feisty firecracker other
times I'm sweet like a teddy bear and I
love to curl up on your lap or follow
you wherever you go like your Shadow get
ready for some kisses I have not
received one kiss from you Shadow
usually animals love me what is your
problem you kind of feel like an older
person's dog I think Shadow's so cute
but I feel offended because Shadow
hasn't kissed me once oh and now you're
leaving me
no no boo-boos
[Music]
Shadow if I pick your parent we're gonna
have to work on our relationship okay
because I want kisses